Hong Kong is a country city autonomous
part of China okay okay
Hong Kong is a tournament art of
People's Republic of China and even
though its role in the modern era is
very significant this small area of two
thousand seven and fifty five square
kilometers inhabited by almost seven and
a half million people wasn't always so
big populist and significant to
understand what exactly I meant by that
we have to look at the history of the
area we call Hong Kong before I start I
would like to say that the area of Hong
Kong and the island of Hong Kong
referred to two different things one
refers to just the island the order to
the whole of today's Hong Kong so in the
video unless I specified by saying
Island when I mentioned Hong Kong I mean
the whole area of today's Hong Kong okay
sources about history of today's Hong
Kong region prior to British
colonisation differ between the European
and Asian European sources which are
primarily British State the history of
Hong Kong is a barren Rock prior to
1840s British colonisation in contrast
the Asian sources primarily Chinese
stayed that the area has been inhabited
for thousands of years and played a
vital role in the history and
development of today's Guangdong County
now considering that almost 6,000 year
old archeological remains of human
settlements have been found in Hong Kong
it is most likely that the Chinese
sources are far more reliable when
looking at the history of the region
prior to the 19th century from these
sources we know that South China along
with Hong Kong was settled by hundred UI
tribes more closely related to Malays
Vietnamese and Polynesians than Han
Chinese the region was largely
undeveloped with farmers and fishermen
living here and there with very low
overall centralization but it is still
most likely that these people did set up
some kind of a political entity in the
area
however we know very little of their
activity before the arrival of the Qin
Dynasty the Qin to control the land and
brought with them the Han Chinese
artistic rats with their fancy
bureaucracy to rule over the peasantry
and this finally created some
much-needed centralization it was also
the Qin Dynasty that said the president
for Han Chinese migration into today's
South China which will continue to
increase over the upcoming years when
the Qin Dynasty fell Hong Kong became
part of a Saturn you a kingdom which was
still ruled by the Han our secrecy
despite majority of the population being
of UI culture later the southern newer
kingdom was incorporated into the
Empire by Emperor Wu of Han it was under
this dynasty that laid check account
home was constructed on Kabul and
Peninsula which was discovered in 1955
the term was constructed in Han Chinese
style how it is unknown for whom as
there were no bodies found also during
the Han Dynasty small-scale pearl
farming started to emerge in type oi-oi
when the Han Dynasty felled the Hongkong
region switched a lot between different
political entities first the eastern
wood and the Jin leo song southern Qi
Liang Cheng Tsui and finally some
stability came under the highly regarded
tang dynasty now during these quick
political changes not just in Hong Kong
region but in all of China many more Han
Chinese migrated to the south of today's
China this was partly due to the
instability and warfare but also partly
due to many new economic opportunities
in the largely undeveloped South
compared to the north this brought new
development to the Hong Kong region and
small-scale industries like
aforementioned pearl farming and also
possibly salt mining started to increase
after the Tang Dynasty collapsed area
fell under the control of the southern
Han Dynasty and then southern Song
Dynasty it was under these two dynasties
that Hong Kong continued to develop
mainly on Kowloon Peninsula this can be
seen in the fact that during the fall of
the southern Song Dynasty under the
hands of the Mongols Gavilan was
regularly cited as the refuge of the
Emperor this prompted the area to be
filled with song loyalists even when
Mongol Yuan Dynasty was established and
that is why through much of the yuan
ruled the region's economy stagnated as
it was inhabited mainly by only farmers
fishermen and pirates between the cusp
of the yuan dynasty falling and the ming
dynasty being established the hong kong
area became under the control of seven
large and wealthy families who owned
most of the land it was under these
family supervision that throughout the
Ming Dynasty many settlers from
Guangdong and Fujian the two prominent
coastal provinces of southern China
migrated to Kowloon Peninsula some of
these people also settled across the
harbor on Hong Kong Island Howard Island
remained largely uninhabited with just a
few small fishing towns it was when the
Ming Dynasty got replaced by the Ching
dynasty in 1644 that the Hong Kong area
along with the island of Hong Kong
became much more incorporated into the
Empire fishing boats from other parts of
China started to use the local Harbor
and
registrar started to be kept on vessels
entering and leaving the harbor
collection of taxes became more
efficient and village elders represented
the area and local government but even
with all of this the area was still
controlled largely by pirates dating
back to the days of the Yuan Dynasty so
in which were the largest names of
Chinese pirate history like Chang first
founder of the pirate confederation and
his wife / daughter-in-law it was cool
because his son was adopted and he was
dead anyways after the pirates were
driven out in 1909 and before the
British arrival the area became a small
but strategically important Harbor and a
military outpost for the Qing Dynasty
most of the people that lived there were
living a simple farmer's life like
anywhere else in China and small village
temples were scattered all around the
hilly area it is almost certain now that
Hong Kong had a history before the
British arrival but how and why did the
British come to hong kong in the first
place well as with all things British it
involved tea and a bigger army diplomacy
you see British were obsessed with tea
to such an extent that it comprised 10%
of the entire British government's
revenue and China having seemingly
endless supply of tea was the market to
be in how our training valuable metals
or expensive manufactured goods for
something that can be grown endlessly
ends up being not good for business for
the British at least so to solve this
problem they started trading cheaply
made drug for another chiefly made drug
the problem was that the British had
such a high demand for tea that the
amount of opium they were importing into
China was staggering it created such an
opium problem in the country that the
emperor couldn't ignore it anymore and
so the First Opium War started before
the war most of the British activity and
trade went through Canton which is
located up the stream from Hong Kong but
that will start to change during the war
preliminary peace talks that later broke
down gave the island of Hong Kong to the
British despite the fact that the talks
broke down the British still decided to
take the island anyways and on 25th of
January 1841 British occupied the island
of Hong Kong for the first time when the
war finally ended Britain officially
gained control over the island in
perpetuity and Hong Kong became a crown
colony operating under British law the
British quickly started to use Hong Kong
as a trading point with China and since
they controlled it they dictated the
terms of the trade within its borders
Hong Kong quickly proved to be a very
valuable port as its location had a pair
big deep harbor which was protected from
typhoons and was easy to access both
from the sea and from mainland China now
firmly under British control Hong Kong
started to undergo drastic changes with
large building projects springing up all
around the island and huge trade deals
being hammered out every day within its
borders and despite what some would have
you believe it wasn't just the British
who got rich off of these endeavours the
Chinese populace which formed the
majority of the population on the island
enjoyed much higher standards of living
than in the surrounding Chinese regions
and it was mostly local Chinese people
that held control over the local trade
companies established by the British
however all wasn't perfect
the sudden change brought up on the area
caused huge influx of European
adventurers and mainland Chinese pouring
into the island this caused a sudden
spike in theft piracy and disease
throughout Hong Kong and to add to all
of this Chinese officials along with the
British on occasion used their lack of
knowledge of the local jurisdiction to
exact ridiculous laws or taxes on
unsuspected citizens on both sides
despite these struggles Hong Kong kept
moving out Christian missions were
established and the economy kept growing
but the British felt like their new
valuable port didn't have much
protection from China and was vulnerable
to attack so during the Second Opium War
in 1860 they pushed for a perpetual
lease of Cavalier Peninsula to serve as
a buffer between the island and China
this buffer quickly became just as
valuable as Hong Kong Island itself and
construction projects on Kowloon began
almost instantly by 1890s Hong Kong's
population was 221 thousand which
compared to just seven and a half
thousand fifty years ago is almost a 30
times increase this increase brought
upon the British let's pray shil /
social status laws against a majority of
the Chinese population ie the official
language was only English Chinese
residents had to carry a lap when
crossing at night and disease outbreak
slit racial zoning most notably at
Victoria Peak horror Hong Kong still
managed to reach many milestones first
electrical and gas companies emerge
rickshaw started to make way to more
European style of transportation Chris
Hospital of Hong Kong was established
along with the first western-style
College etc all these changes increased
the value of Hong Kong for the British
but the increased value also sparked the
British fear of losing it to some
foreign power yet again and so they
struck another deal with China there
the second convention of Beijing to
acquire even more land this time not in
perpetuity but for 99 years by 1898 Hong
Kong was finally the size it is now
well mostly the turn of the century it
became obvious that even though Hong
Kong was under the British jurisdiction
its ups and downs were very much
dictated by the economic and political
status of neighboring China and as the
Ching dynasty was very much struggling
to keep afloat the boom of Hong Kong
started to slow down nonetheless the
University of Hong Kong was founded in
1911 as a highly regarded institution
which he continues to be to this day and
that same year the Chinese Revolution
brought down the last dynasty and
created the Republic of China hardison
tyrant he was very unstable and many
warlords held most of the power in
various areas of China such instability
on the mainland brought even more
Chinese immigrants into Hong Kong who
now worked in the many newly built
factories in the colony this cheap
labour proved valuable to the British
during the great war as Hong Kong played
an important part in supplying Britain
with manufactured goods after the war
the sizeable emigration still continued
and this started to cause large problems
for the British as Hong Kong interwar
period was dictated by many riots
strikes and boycotts prior to the Hong
Kong's involvement in world war ii the
population of Hong Kong swelled up to
well over a million and a half people
most of whom were fleeing the Japanese
Empire aid of December 1941 the same
morning of Pearl Harbor attack Hong Kong
was invaded by the Japanese forces under
the Japanese occupation inflation was
rampant thousands of civilians were
killed rape starving and/or deported out
of Hong Kong and all of this resulted in
the population loss of a million people
by the end of the war when the Japanese
finally surrendered Hong Kong was
restored back to the British head
however a new problem started to emerge
the Chinese Communist revolution in 1949
due to this Hong Kong yet again
experienced a large influx of
immigration but in this case it proved
to be very valuable as it replenished
labor pool lost during World War two
this replenish labor pool was now being
backed up by a large inflow of Chinese
firms
relocating to Hong Kong also due to the
Communist revolution manufacturing
industry started to increase yet again
and the words made in Hong Kong started
to be synonymous with quality rather
than cheap low-grade production but
economic boom started to hit a bump in
the road due to its focus on
manufacturing which now more stable and
modernized PRC was much better at Hong
Kong had to pivot an oppa mitad date is
a capitalistic system in a communist
world which now opened its markets Hong
Kong managed to become one of the most
valuable financial and transshipment
ports in the world I also finally became
less colonial II and many laws for equal
rights and pay including for a woman
were passed throughout the later half of
the 20th century but the new problem the
horizon was the least time of 99 years
was closing in and the PRC was more than
eager to regain control of such a
valuable area however if you follow it
closely only the 1898 Treaty for New
Territories was signed for 99 years
which didn't include plum balloon and or
Hong Kong Island nevertheless the way
the British acquired these holdings
wasn't very peaceful the UN doesn't
favor collin ism splitting the new
colonies from the rest with the
resulting huge problems and the PRC well
insisted on getting all of Hong Kong
back this resulted in Hong Kong becoming
part of the PRC under the one country
two systems' row in 1997 which means
that Hong Kong is left alone to certain
extent to maintain its politics and
economy at least until 2040 s this deal
depending on who you ask is either great
or not-so-great
despite all of that Hong Kong today
holds the highest financial Development
Index it's the world's seventh-largest
trading entity has the most skyscrapers
in the world has the world's highest
life expectancy has one of the highest
per capita income etc Hong Kong right
now was strong modern and resilient how
its future seems foggy
the name of Hong Kong came from either a
phonetic rendering of the spoken
Cantonese in the area which looked like
this an or can be traced at a tunc of
people who used a Hong Kong Island for
mostly fishing the meaning of the name
is something like fragrant Harbor or
incense harbor fragrance due to the
inflow of new water through the parallel
river and or incense due to the incense
production and Kowloon which could be
smelt on Hong Kong Island regardless of
the origin the word used to be spelled
together like this Howard that was
changed in 1926 and from that we have
today's Hong Kong if you enjoyed the
video please share subscribe and/or
consider supporting me on patreon thank
you until next time my name is my sir